le cyclone hugo est passé sur la
guadeloupe on redoute des dégâts
matériels importants pas de victime
annoncée pour l'instant des secours sont
déjà acheminé sur place le font avec le
ministre des départements et territoires
d'outre-mer
monsieur le pensec en direct dans ce
journal ce soir à paris rue de rennes le
président de la république et le maire
de la capitale jacques chirac ont
dévoilé une plaque à la mémoire de
toutes les victimes d'attentats
terroristes
ils proposeront une enquête sur la
réalité de la solidarité envers les
victimes innocentes de cette violence
aveugle
après un mois de prison à kaboul
kinésithérapeute français xavier lemire
libre rentrer à paris dès ce soir sur le
plateau de cette édition de 20 ans voilà
monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de ce
dimanche soir c'est d'abord la situation
en guadeloupe et en martinique les deux
îles des antilles françaises ont été
atteintes par le cyclone hugo c'est
surtout la guadeloupe qui a été touchée
avec des vents dépassant les 200 km
heure il faut s'attendre à des dégâts
matériels assez importants
heureusement pour l'instant on ne
déplore pas officiellement de victimes
mais déjà des sans abri le gouvernement
a donc décidé dès cet après-midi
d'expédier sur place les premiers
secours et des premiers renforts de
personnel spécialisé
le cyclone hugo qui est l'un des plus
violents enregistrés depuis dix ans
n'est pas sur le point de se calmer il
poursuit même sa route vers d'autres
îles de l'atlantique notamment porto
rico la route du cyclone décrite
maintenant par notre spécialiste météo
jose dans la pierre et bien tout d'abord
je voudrais vous montrer l'ampleur de ce
cyclone regardez plutôt 450 km de
diamètre une masse tourbillonnante dans
le sens inverse des aiguilles d'une
montre qu'il déplace d'est en ouest à 20
25 kilomètres à l'heure en hauteur
jusqu'à 18 km d'altitude
donc une énergie déployée qui correspond
à celle de plusieurs bombes atomiques à
l'heure au centre l'oeil du cyclone qui
correspond à une zone de temps calme 15
km environ mais autour de l'oeil du
cyclone
c'est là où c'est le plus dangereux
c'est là où les vents vont jusqu'à 250
voire 270 km à l'heure c'est donc cette
partie la plus active qui a traversé
aujourd'hui le nord de la guadeloupe
comme vous pouvez le constater la
martinique se trouvait donc disons à la
périphérie
et n'a subi des vents que 200 kilomètres
à l'heure mais tout de même de fortes
pluies alors cette partie active est
actuellement sur les antilles
hollandaises voilà et si bien que saint
martin que vous voyez ci et saint
barthélémy se trouve comme la martinique
disons à la périphérie donc des gens
plus modérée 100 kilomètres à l'heure
mais tout de même de fortes pluies alors
maintenant les prévisions c'est porto
rico demain qui sera touché aux environs
de 14 heures heure de paris
le cyclone le gros du cyclone devrait
passer à l'ouest de la capitale san juan
on va voir tout de suite quelques images
car les habitants ont là aussi été
prévenus et se préparent les radios
diffusent consignes sur consigne
notamment de console ou des toits
fenêtres et des vitres et de mettre à
l'abri tout objet susceptible de se
transformer en projectile et surtout
surtout de rester chez soi ou alors de
rejoindre les abris anticycloniques qui
existe dans les écoles ou bien les
salles communales
voilà daniel ce que l'on peut dire
actuellement merci monsieur ministre
remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce soir d'abord une première
question des radios américaines font
état de rumeurs expliquant qu'il y
aurait une soixantaine de victimes
d'ores et déjà en guadeloupe à la suite
du passage du cyclone hugo est ce que
c'est exact est ce que ces informations
peuvent être confirmés il faut dire que
la difficulté d'établir des liaisons
fiable conduit à prendre avec une grande
réserve de telles annonces à 18 heures
nous avons pu joindre le responsable de
la gendarmerie qui faisait état qu à sa
connaissance il n'y avait aucun mort il
y a depuis quelques dizaines de minutes
des informations plutôt des rumeurs peu
concordantes selon lesquelles il y
aurait trois bords bien
alors donc pour l'instant peu ou pas de
victimes
il y à des bus et les blessés étaient de
blessés notamment sur la côte est et les
sans abri les sans abri depuis plusieurs
heures on avance le chiffre de plusieurs
milliers ceci me semble une estimation
je dirais qui peut être accepté
en dépit de toutes les mesures
préventives il faut bien voir que la
nature de l'habitat la force du cyclone
aussi qu'il a été dit ont touché plus
précisément
les habitats qui sont je crois pour ce
qui est des dégâts l'aspect le plus
important
alors qui dit sans abri dit dégâts
matériels relativement important dès cet
après-midi des renforts ont été envoyés
et du matériel sur place
le fait que nous disposions de
prévisions nous ont permis de prendre un
certain nombre de dispositions et
notamment en totale coordination et de
monsieur pierre joxe l'envoi des
premiers secours
ces unités sont partis d'autres vont
suivre mais il est capital que le préfet
de la guadeloupe puisse dire ce que sont
ses véritables besoins et comme le
cyclone il y à quelques minutes faisait
encore sentir ses effets il est
difficile de bien cerner les besoins
ceci étant des avions sont à nouveau je
dirais sur pied de départ moyen mais il
me sera donné demain deux raisons le
joyau papa milliard de partir en
guadeloupe et nous avons aussi décidé
cet après midi en réunion
interministérielle de réformer ce que
seront les procédures d'indemnisation
mais je voulais vous dire que tantôt
ministère de l'intérieur au ministère
des dom tom c'est un état de veille
permanent monsieur le ministre merci
après un mois de détention en
afghanistan libération du
kinésithérapeute français xavier lemire
membres de l'organisation handicap
international qui avait été fait
prisonnier dans une embuscade tendue par
les troupes de kaboul à un groupe de la
résistance afghane
xavier lemire est arrivé ce matin à
roissy où l'attendaient sa famille
reportage de thierry calmette et noël
alex en gymnase
premier moment d'intimité familiale pour
xavier le meilleur mais la joie ne peut
être complète
difficile de le dire en public mais aux
amis d'handicap international à ses
frères et soeurs javier se doit de
raconter la fin de vincent gernigon
l'embuscade du 14 août
là bas en afghanistan j'ai gueulé à
vincent merde plan de pont moi je me
suis couché
monsieur complètement couchés sur la
banquette et vincent lui moi j'ai pas vu
ce qu'il a fait son coup ce que vont je
suis complètement aplati
mais bon ce qu'il a fait il est dit
c'est qu'on attache est comme ça il fait
allonger la fusillade est parti
pratiquement aussitôt donc lui était
dans la position que j'ai décrit tout à
l'heure où il est il était très blanc
mais très calme il regardait fixement
droit devant lui semblait pas blessée à
ce moment et ses symboles et en enjeux
lagarde et qui là qu'il a reçu une balle
et qui est qui pour moi était dans une
balle reçue par la poitrine
il a poussé un soupir et il est mort sur
le coup
sur la terrasse le père de xavier
médecin lui aussi évalue les chances de
survie une efficacité des soins
sa mère et ses soeurs lui raconte le
drame vécu depuis ici en france le plus
éprouvant pour une mère l'incertitude
bien sûr et surtout l'imagination qui
galope je voyais me rendre safar'wii
j'imagine une seule chose qu'on est là
c'est pas si c'est à dire mais je
j'étais en contact famille gernigon et à
ce moment là j'étais en contact de façon
aisée j'ai eu la grand mère et je dis
madame je vous envie presque de savoir
ce qu'est devenu votre enfant parce que
nous ne savons rien et après par contre
quand j'y suis que vous aviez des
prisonniers chanter que je n'étais pas
vraiment tellement privilégiée par
rapport à cette famille ça me faisait
mal dans l'autre sens et que c'est eux
qui ont dû m'appeler passage obligatoire
dans son récit à la famille pour
rassurer la description d'un ray sur
pare-balles rappelés chez nous les
vendre l'articulation et surtout
l'évocation de sa chance inouïe où l'on
traversé de part en part et aucun organe
aucun vaisseau touché la famille lemire
vie dispersés à travers le monde
xavier n'avait pas revu son frère aîné
patrice depuis six ans dans le jardin la
conversation fraternelle se poursuit
nous nous sommes partis voilà examiner
l'avenir a eu la gentillesse ce soir de
nous réserver ce premier entretien
télévisé xavier vrai qu'on revient dans
l'instant vous l'avez évoqué dans le
reportage sur les circonstances de
l'embuscade d'un seul coup vous êtes
passés de je dirais de témoins acteurs
ben oui enfin ça l'embuscade
nous on était parti avec le
le camion sur une route avec un groupe
de résistants que oui qui était sur
normande est traversé le désert du
registan directement et c'est un ennui
technique qui m'a malgré un camion tout
terrain qui nous a empêché de continuer
cette route et on était obligé de faire
demi tour pour prendre une route
différente c'est là que les ailes et la
queue
l'embuscade s'est déroulé s'est déroulé
tout s'est passé très très vite est ce
qu'on réalise à ce moment là je pourrais
pas dire le temps combien de temps sa
durée mais ça peut être duré dix minutes
un quart d'heure mais ce temps c'est
l'enfer quoi ce quelle a été l'attitude
des troupes officielles de kaboul
lorsqu'elle vous ont capturé et puis
nous évoquons ensuite votre votre
incarcération ces interrogatoires qui
ont duré pendant un mois
voilà dix ans la première réaction des
des militaires après la taxer
son sous l'attention de l'attaqué les
réactions haute et agressive
ils m'ont sorti du camion ils m'ont
traîné à 20 30 mètres du site de la
bataille
ils m'ont complètement dépouillé et puis
j'avais déjà des réactions agressives
puis après j'ai été placé sur un camion
et j'ai reçu les premiers soins et un
médecin infirmier qui est venu me voir
j'ai pu entrer en contact avec eux alors
parlons activités qui vous attire voilà
je leur ai dit que j'étais un médecin un
kinésithérapeute que j'étais venu pour
faire du matériel orthopédique des
prothèses des tout ça on l'a le rapport
est devenu déjà fier d'être différent et
beaucoup plus sympathique
le séjour en prison à kaboul et à
l'hôpital interrogatoire successifs
quotidien pour ainsi dire quotidien est
paru le vendredi qu'elle était un jour
férié chez eux puis de trois jours dans
le mois où je n'avais pas
d'interrogatoire mais sinon c'était oui
est ce que vous aviez l'impression vous
alliez être libéré ou ça a été une
surprise de ta peau je perds mon avis je
pensais que ça prendrait plus de temps
c'était il y avait des bruits qui
couraient vers le mois d'octobre
et puis data et puis ces jours derniers
un jour ils vous ont sorti de l'hôpital
sortie de wii ils m'ont dit prenez vos
affaires je croyais à changer de chambre
et ça a été terminé alors beaucoup
d'organismes ont concouru à votre
libération le gouvernement français
nations unies aussi on le sait peut-être
- les nations unies ont énormément
participé
pour ma libération et les demandes des
tas de gens d'état d'organismes qui ont
participé et mais les nations unies ont
été vraiment sûrs ont eu un rôle
primordial pas
un dans ma libération dernière question
peut-être allez-vous réagir à cette
question je pensais pas que des hommes
comme vous prennent un certain nombre de
risques inconsidérés en se rendant là
bas sur place tels qu'ils le font tel
que vous l'avez fait que d'autres l'ont
fait cheminement je pense pas que ce
soit vraiment des risques inconsidérés
c'était quand même bon à un programme
qui est financée patronné par les
nations unies bon handicap international
sous c'est quand même mais aussi une
association que je considère comme
sérieuse
ce qui à certains risques c'est sur
place je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
malchance aussi d'un problème technique
qui a fait que et la chance qu'il
revienne
puisque vous êtes libéré 20 pour moi
c'est sûr j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
merci le 17 septembre 1986 c'est à dire
il y a trois ans de cela à 18h30 une
bombe explosait dans un grand magasin au
142 la rue de rennes très exactement à
paris faisant 7 morts et 60 blessés
la france connaissait alors souvenez
vous une vague d'attentats liés aux
événements du proche orient il y à
quelques instants à peine à l'initiative
de l'organisation sos attentats et bien
le président de la république monsieur
mitterrand et le maire de paris jacques
chirac ont dévoilé une plaque sur les
lieux mêmes de ce terrible attentat une
manière de rendre hommage un hommage
global à toutes les victimes de la
violence et de la lâcheté des
terroristes bernard pradines au palis
rien
à l'époque de l'attentât en septembre 86
une véritable psychose de peur s'était
développée à paris en province
c'est ce que cherchait les terroristes
mais les sept victimes de la rue de
rennes allait en fait déclenché une
réaction très vive du gouvernement le
président de la république et le premier
ministre jacques chirac
le gouvernement tout entier et l'elysée
c'était serré les coudes si l'on peut
dire
tout comme la police et la population la
surveillance accrue et la lutte contre
le terrorisme ramener le calme dans la
capitale
ce soir l'absence d'un protocole pesant
à donner à cette cérémonie une chaleur
et une dignité qui ont fait venir les
larmes aux yeux des familles de ses
victimes
monsieur mitterrand et monsieur chirac
ont parlé longuement à ces familles et
plus encore que la plaque du souvenir et
les gerbes de fleurs ce contact est sans
doute pour tous un symbole encore plus
réelle d'intérêt
cet attentat de la rue de rennes je le
disais il y à quelques instants
s'inscrivait alors dans une spirale de
la violence qui pouvait nous toucher
tous aveuglément indifféremment mais ces
événements passés et bien la solidarité
résiste-t-elle autant en quête de denise
bauer et jean-françois au chemin rien ne
viendra effacer la douleur de ce couple
monsieur et madame bismuth ont voulu par
ces quelques mots gravés dans la pierre
que l'oubli ne s'installe pour les
victimes du terrorisme
c'était le 7 juillet 88 en grèce un
command ouvrent le feu sur les passagers
d'un bateau le city of toros bilan plus
de 90 morts par milieu trois jeunes
touristes français isabelle bismuth
thierry vigneron et à niveau de gens à
faire nos propres qualités que ma fille
est mort pour elle est toujours vivante
elle a toujours l'espoir de leur voix
souffre
on souffre parce que tu as perdu un
enfant un parent on souffre parce que
rien n'y fasse tout le mal qui a été
fait qui a été dit en effet à la suite
d'une terrible méprise les autorités
grecques désigne ces trois jeunes gens
comme étant des complices du commando
vous nous pour nos amis n'a jamais été
simple pour les autres je pense que pour
certains un doute persiste et où il peut
avoir été un terroriste parce que
pendant six mois on aide qu'ils étaient
terroristes pendant 24 heures on a dit
qu'il n'était pas officiellement mais je
n'ai rien au chagrin s'ajoutent parfois
l'oubli et le désintéressement
le temps n'est pourtant pas si loin où
vous était donné de voir ces images
presque quotidiennement
goldenberg copernic rue marbeuf grand
véfour galerie points chauds hôtel de
ville sonacotra tati la liste serait
trop longue de ces noms de ces lieux où
le terrorisme a frappé en 15 ans faisant
plus de 70 morts et plus de mille
blessés
certaines de ces victimes sont
handicapés à vie des enfants orphelins
c'est pour eux que l'association sos
attentats se bat depuis trois ans une
chose est de 100% pour toutes les
victimes et ensuite le statut de
victimes de guerre de façon que les
enfants soient pris en charge pour
l'éducation jusqu'à leur majorité
c'est en bonne voie on espère avoir
satisfaction
ce soir la france rendait un hommage à
ces victimes du terrorisme
ces férus de rennes le 17 septembre 86
un attentat a tué sept personnes en
blessaient 54
les conflits qui régulièrement
malheureusement des chaînes cette
violence terroriste dans le monde
persiste comme celui du liban qui
connaît aujourd'hui une énième tentative
de la part de la ligue des pays arabes
nouvelle initiative de paix donc
encourager officiellement par toutes les
parties en présence
mais pour l'instant le canon continuent
de tonner à beyrouth michel mompontet
d'un côté pour le liban il y a une fois
encore l'espoir à djeddah hier soir en
arabie saoudite
le comité tripartite de la ligue arabe
publie un plan de règlement en sept
points du conflit appels au
cessez-le-feu immédiat cessation des
livraisons d'armes aux belligérants et
fin du blocus maritime et terrestre sur
le réduit chrétiens voilà pour les
points positifs mais dans ce texte c'est
le profil bas qui domine le plus petit
dénominateur diplomatique commun des
différentes parties en présence dans la
région
jamais en effet la syrie n'est cité
jamais le retrait des troupes
israéliennes et syriennes du liban
n'était évoquée si plusieurs pays arabes
si la france est si les états unis se
sont déjà réjoui le scepticisme est ce
soir bien évidemment encore dominants et
pour cause malgré un apparent retour au
calme dans beyrouth
l'appel au cessez-le-feu immédiat de la
ligue arabe n'a pas empêché des échanges
de feu sur les murs de ces immeubles les
impacts d'obus de la veille comme un
défi à tout plan de paix
en france le professeur robert faurisson
auteur d'une thèse visant à nier
l'existence des fours crématoires dans
les camps de concentration a été je vous
le rappelle victime d'une agression hier
à vichy agression revendiqué par une
organisation inconnue les fils de la
mémoire juive le professeur dont l'état
de santé est jugé satisfaisant a tout de
même subi ce matin une intervention
chirurgicale de quatre heures à
l'hôpital de clermont ferrand il
souffrait notamment de fractures au
visage pour des raisons qui ne sont
évidemment pas les mêmes
la licra la ligue internationale contre
le racisme et l'antisémitisme et le
délégué du front national monsieur
maigret condamnant ensemble cet attentat
quant à serge klarsfeld
l'avocat qui a consacré sa vie à la
recherche des anciens nazis criminels de
guerre il déclare qu'il faut s'attendre
à ce genre d'événement ajoutant on ne
peut pas insulter la mémoire des
victimes sans qu'il y ait des
conséquences en pologne dans une
interview à un magazine catholique
monseigneur glem revient sur ses
positions extrémistes à propos du carmel
d'auschwitz il faut dit-il faire appel à
la compréhension mutuelle par ailleurs
il n'oppose plus un non catégorique au
transfert des carmélites à l'extérieur
de l'enceinte du camp de concentration à
l'est encore et enfin le gouvernement
soviétique annonce le lancement d'un
important emprunt de 643 milliards de
francs intérêts 5% destinées à réduire
le déficit budgétaire de l'urss et
l'aider dans sa politique économique
menace de pollution limité jusqu'à
présent du moins mais bien réelle dans
la manche au large des côtes de
l'angleterre deux pétroliers se sont
heurtés ce matin l'abordage n'a fait
heureusement aucune victime mais une
nappe de pétrole de 6 km de long a été
repérée s'échappant des soutes des deux
navires qui a eu de transport plus de
100 mille tonnes de pétrole véronique
gaglione
quatre heures de lutte contre les
flammes et le feu est éteint mais la
collision des deux pétroliers laisse en
mer du nord une large plaie noir une
nappe de pétrole d'environ 8 km de long
sur 500 mètres répondu à l'embouchure de
la inverse sur la côte nord-est de
l'angleterre
c'est à 10h30 heure de paris que
l'accident a eu lieu ce matin le fiona
battant pavillon libérien mouillé au
large de kingston lorsque le navire
maltais philips oklahoma l'a
vraisemblablement heurtée au total près
de 100 mille tonnes de combustible les
deux bâtiments se sont immédiatement
embrasé les 55 membres d'équipage des
deux pétroliers ont été évacués
tous sains et saufs les ce matin des
avions commencé à déverser des produits
spéciaux sur la nappe de pétrole
une nappe qui continue de s'étaler à la
surface de l'eau reste aujourd'hui à
préciser la cause de l'accident
les conditions climatiques de ce début
de matinée et est cependant favorable
semaine importante qui s'annonce dans le
conflit peugeot l'union syndicale s'est
réalisée avec la participation des
cadres de la cgt pour ne pas accepter
les propositions salariales faites par
le pdg jacques fallait jacques calvet
girard locale demain 7 à paris sous les
fenêtres même du pdg jacques élevé que
12 cents grévistes de mulhouse venus par
train spécial manifesteront demander
l'ouverture de négociations
ils auront été précédée dès 9 heures du
matin par une délégation des cadres cgc
de peugeot qui se plaignent du rôle que
la direction leur fait jouer et menacent
d'intervenir à leur tour estimant que
jacques calvet est un excellent manager
sur le plan technique sur le plan
économique personnelle en parfait il les
incompétents aujourd'hui sur le plan
social nous estimons donc il faut qu'ils
aient l'humilité de se rendre compte de
cette situation et qu' il puisse donc se
ressaisir pour ouvrir le dialogue
s'il ne le fait pas c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous nous adressons également
ou conseil d'administration de
l'entreprise qui après tout la nommer et
qui peut demander faire éventuellement
la direction elle maintient la fermeté
chaque salarié de sochaux a reçu une
lettre lui demandant de reprendre le
travail dans le calme
à mulhouse les grévistes sont convoqués
pour un entretien préalable avant des
sanctions disciplinaires
les syndicats leur demande de ne pas s'y
rendre et appelle un renforcement du
mouvement à sochaux avant son extension
à d'autres usines du groupe en 10 jours
de conflit c'est la production de 14
mille voitures qui a déjà été perdu ou
plongeon on imagine aisément ans il
complice poursuit cette semaine ils
risquent de déborder largement sur le
plan politique et déjà aujourd'hui au
forum rmc fr 3 monsieur emmanuelli le
numéro deux du parti socialiste s'est
interrogé sur les méthodes de monsieur
calvet en matière sociale monsieur
emmanuel nous estimons qu'il n'est pas
normal qu'une direction ne veulent pas
ouvrir de négociations en 1989 avec des
salariés en grève
nous estimons aussi pour ma part
j'estime avec force que les méthodes
employées par à la direction de peugeot
ne font pas honneur à la démocratie
française nos patronne en général reste
une pierre dans le jardin mais s'est
calmé menace les huissiers les
déménagements de machines le chantage la
compétitivité c'est un vieil argument
quand monsieur kg de sucre élevé dont
nous voulons qu'il y ait des leçons
comme des affaires publiques par la
compétition avec les lois existent et on
peut pas s'opposer systématiquement à
des revendications sociales sous
prétexte que hong kong en corée ou à
venir les salaires sont plus bas
ça fait quand même dix neuvième siècle
ça fait pas 21e siècle or dans la
compétitivité
il ya aujourd'hui tout de même quelque
chose d'important ce sont les relations
humaines c'est la politique sociale
d'entreprise de ce point de vue là
quoique il faudrait peut-être que
monsieur calvet subi des stages de
formation
voilà on change maintenant radicalement
de préoccupation et de sujets avec cet
été qui se termine et qui n'aura pas été
le même pour tout le monde il ya en
effet plusieurs façons de prendre ses
vacances
ainsi chaque année des jeunes se rendent
pour un séjour à l'abbaye de taizé en
saône-et-loire et
dans le calme de ce monastère et bien
ils réfléchissent ensemble aux sens
qu'ils doivent donner à leur vie dans
cette société de fin du xxème siècle on
vient d'en parler à l'instant qui ne
sait à quelle valeur se raccrocher qui
ne soit pas simplement matériel
reportages de marque maisonneuve et jean
corbeil tous les jours à trois reprises
immuablement la priait une prière
commune dans l'église de la
réconciliation symbole de taizé une
communauté monastique dont le but
affiché est leur rapprochement entre les
hommes et cela quelle que soit leur
religion
autour de son fondateur frère roger 90
frères d'une vingtaine de nationalités
depuis 1957 dix ans après sa création
des centaines de milliers de jeunes se
sont rendus dans cette communauté
ils sont venus d'europe puis de tous les
autres continents attiré par un désir
d'ouverture
ils sont hyper sont pas des moments
découragement de leur vie ils
s'affublent outre affronter des
événements multiples mais ils savent que
s'ils n'acceptent pas ne consomme pas
par c'est aussi à travers les vous et je
vais demande du redevable
ils ne pourront rien créé ils seront
tous absents ils seront dans un nageur
pendant une semaine au moins les jeunes
apprennent à réfléchir non pas sur eux
mêmes mais sur la nécessité d'être
solidaires des autres
le monde dans lequel ils vivent est le
leur emmanuel bien de yaoundé au
cameroun
je rencontre des personnes qui viennent
d'asie qui viennent dayraut qui gênent
d'amérique et ça me permet d'avoir
également une vue du verset chez de ce
qui se passe dans le monde chaque
semaine de 35 à 70 nations différentes
se retrouvent ensemble leurs expériences
de vie tranche les unes avec les autres
cette jeune colombienne côtoie
quotidiennement la violence aucun doute
l'espérance c'est que le christ nous
change qui nous enlève notre coeur de
pierre et nous donne un vrai coeur
d'amour d'amitié et de paix dernier
stade des passes margaret vient de
gdansk eu l'idée du dévouement lui est
familière mais sa réponse est simple
lorsqu'on lui demande si elle est
attirée par la vie religieuse je veux
une grande famille
ceux qui sont là réfléchissent pour que
leur croyance ne les mette jamais à
l'écart de leur vie ni de celle des
autres
s'il est convenu de dire que les
français n'aiment pas la géographie ce
qui est encore à vérifier et bien ils
aiment leur histoire ou plutôt moins
leurs monuments historiques cette année
encore tout au long de ce dimanche de
septembre est bien tous les monuments et
des bâtiments officiels même ceux qui
sont habituellement interdite au public
et est aujourd'hui donc ouvert et à
paris le ministre de la culture en
personne monsieur jack lang servait de
guide aux visites
valérie fournis ou philippe dumas y ont
enquêté certains se sont même levés très
tôt pour un dimanche dès 9 heures la
foule se pressait devant les portes du
palais royal
pourquoi vous êtes venus ici ce matin
d'une part pour me promenais d'autres
pour dissiper par intérêt de voir un
petit peu ce que l'on ne peut pas avoir
normalement et bien suivez le guide dont
l'amateur et cette visite
y compris pour moi même c'est de
parcourir l'ensemble de
du palais un guide bien insolite et de
marques qui dévoile à un public venu
parfois de province les salons et les
antichambres de ce lieu qui a vu passer
richelieu comme anne d'autriche
ces passionnés je suis ministre ça ne
vous fait pas drôle de serre visiter
votre bureau pourquoi ça me fait drôle
je trouve ça je sais pas vous ne pas
interroger cette personne se retrouve
plutôt que moi donc c'est très agréable
au contraire que des visiteurs viennent
de voir où les responsables travaillent
après tout ce n'est pas ma propriété
personnelle une certaine façon de faire
entrer le quotidien dans l'histoire de
familiariser le public aux monuments
historiques
parfois il faut y mettre du sien comme
ici au désert de retz est inspiré dans
ses architectures par les idées phares
du siècle des lumières
un lieu magique imaginé par thomas
jefferson et construit au xviiie siècle
qui a fait naufrage dans le nôtre
mêleront l'avait sorti de l'oubli
il est aujourd'hui question de le
restaurer le ministère a débloqué les
subventions comme quoi il faut parfois
attendre longtemps pour que notre regard
s'arrête sur le passé une croisade qui
n'en finit pas celle là malgré
l'interdiction de vente de l'ivoire
décidée par les plus importants pays du
monde les trafiquants ne désarme pas de
leur côté la police namibienne vient en
effet d'effectuer une prise très
spectaculaire anne brizolier c'est sans
doute l'une des plus importantes saisies
d'ivoire effectuée dans le cadre d'une
opération anti braconnage 980 défenses
d'éléphants ont été confisqués par la
police namibienne 7 tonnes d'ivoire qui
représente près de 10 millions francs
les auteurs du trafic si namibien
interpellé à okondja ville située au
nord de windhoek la capitale de l'année
by la police suspecte les malfaiteurs
d'appartenir à un réseau de trafiquants
dont certains membres ont déjà été
arrêtées en namibie pour implication
dans divers trafics notamment de corne
de rhinocéros
cette fois la cargaison transportée par
camion provenaient d'éléphants du sud de
l'angola et du nord de la namibie
voilà plus prosaïquement il me reste à
vous donner les résultats du tiercé du
quarté + qui se courait cet après midi à
longchamp pour gagner le tiercé vous
deviez jouer le 5 le 11 et le neuf et
pour ce qui concerne le quarté + c'est
bien vous ajoutez à ces trois chiffres
le 14 pour gagner un peu plus de 3000
francs voilà ce journal est terminée
tout de suite après les prévisions météo
josé dans la pierre le dernier journal
aux alentours de 23h 50 présenté par
philippe gassot je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée une excellente semaine
et avec toute l'équipe du week-end je le
retrouve samedi poche fois
à